I had a no desire ever to marry i am i
feared marriage day the truth ironically
the marriages that i knew the marriage
they knew best was my parents marriage
was just a very healthy wonderful
marriage sixty years and i but i also i
thought the marriage my parents being
partners in this in the business having
a store and told you we're very close in
day and night it was almost
claustrophobic lee close and they had
only two children i'm i was the
firstborn there was a daughter born four
years after me so the four of us were in
this very tight family in these very
tight quarters and my parents were so
compatible almost the expense of their
children where they were they were moon
and I felt that the marriage they had
was just too close and suffocating me so
I don't there's no freedom there they
were under the gun I mean my mother and
father were really out of sight of one
another my father never would make trips
without my mother here he they were
there together all the time this
togetherness was was a was obsessive at
least I felt so so I felt I never want
to be so linked to another person I
wouldn't have a sense of X adventure
exploration or the option of doing
things on my own without necessarily
announcing in advance what I wanted to
do I wanted I wanted to to my ambition
as a young boy was to travel freely not
to have an itinerary not to be committed
not to be committed does one of the
major things to a person or to a
situation not to be dependent I won
freedom journalism afforded that I mean
of all the occupations if I were a
doctor I wouldn't be free out of a you
know the the confinement of the career
of being a medical physician or anything
I want it to be free I wanted to write
about other people to escape a lot of
escape is in my mentality with the
desire to escape into other people's
stories that's all a matter of getting
outside yours
of
not important you know what's really
important it's more important than love
respect what keeps the marriage together
is not love what keeps a marriage or
what keeps a relationship together
whether it's marriage or relationship
outside of marriage a committed
relationship it's respect
no one can define love she's like you
know one sometimes people associate sex
with love you know boy I'm in love I'm
in love you could be in love you know
and in a way that you can maybe convince
yourself is a definition that subscribes
that this particular to you it's very
vague what is not very vague is respect
if you don't have respect for a person
especially a spouse there's no way that
really that relationship can survive
respect you lose respect for a person
it's all over they could be the sexiest
person the most beautiful person the
greatest sexual mate they could perform
you know all the acts of physical love
in ways unmatched in the universe but if
there's no reason if it's the limited
respect or not not great amounts of
respect it's over it's over
sex is not important in marriage
no you want to know more ask me a better
question but it's true
sex is done important sex is very
temporarily important in the beginning
because the the quest for for
companionship and compatibility is
certainly fostered by active and
fulfilling sex sexual experience
absolutely true sex is in the beginning
of the mating game very important sex is
the lure the allure of a woman who can
who can through sexual appeal attract a
man who was attracted to her because
she's sexy
because in bed she's very very
fulfilling but that's okay for a while
that's not going to carry you through
years oh the only thing it's going to
carry you to years is being compatible
with the person having a lot in common
shared values and I keep repeating
respect for one another that is it
without that without respect the game is
over
kept the marriage together during times
of stress and there were certainly many
times stress as in any relationship and
certainly in our kind of marriage there
was because I was traveling a lot my
research I would go all over the place
sometimes to other countries I'm well
beyond my Frank Sinatra experience every
times when I go live in Italy for two or
three years when I started reading long
books after my magazine career ended I
was writing books exclusively and some
of them would take me five or six years
to research four or five books that I
wrote from the 1960s to the 2006 that
last were books of the seven or eight
years of being on the road while staying
married the reason it wasn't so
stressful for my wife nan with whom I've
been married now 50 years in 2009 we
were married in 1959 and 50 years is
this year one of the reasons is that it
wasn't so stressful
she always had full-time a full-time
career she could no less than me fulfill
herself in her work her work became as
she became older and more skilled
recognized there's their books now
called nan talese books nan talese books
/ Doubleday she's and she's got her own
career her writers are among among the
best
there's Margaret Atwood there's there's
Ian McEwan there's Antonia Fraser
there's Pat Conroy there's Barry
Unsworth there's all kinds of
distinguished literary writers that are
published under her imprint and so it
isn't like she's ever lived through me
as there were then ever she was never
just gates Lisa's wife never I mean she
wouldn't mind I don't I don't mean to
suggest that she's she's very
publicity-hungry or that she needs
reassurance by having her name on the
product but she happens to have her name
on the product her books so she's had
her independence and it was so different
from my mother and father who were
people in the store and day and night
within reach of one another and scrutiny
of one another and
I believe I had a lot of freedom from
beginning and through the 50 years and I
think that's kept this marriage together